culpable así se declaró la estrella del
baloncesto estadounidense brittney
griner durante el segundo día de juicio
por los cargos de contrabando y tráfico
de drogas la medallista olímpica de 32
años fue arrestada el pasado 17 de
febrero en un aeropuerto de moscú cuando
autoridades locales encontraron aceite
de cannabis en su equipaje
mérida ella admitió que el aceite de
cannabis era suyo pero dijo que lo trajo
sin querer a rusia porque tenía prisa y
estaba empacando fue solo por accidente
que terminó en su equipaje
josh para acceder su caso se presenta en
un momento tenso en las relaciones entre
eeuu y rusia fue detenida una semana
antes de la invasión a ucrania ella está
siendo injustamente detenida el mosco en
este momento este es un tema que es una
prioridad para el presidente byd en el
kremlin ha dicho que graner violó las
leyes rusas y que no hay motivos
políticos de por medio porque fue según
moscú sorprendida cometiendo un crimen
los seguidores del atleta colegas y su
esposa han pedido su liberación
estoy frustrada porque han pasado 140
días desde que mi esposa ha podido
hablar conmigo con nuestra familia y con
nuestros amigos estoy frustrada porque
mi esposa no va a obtener justicia
demasiado entusiastas
su próxima audiencia será el 14 de julio
donde podría recibir una sentencia de
hasta 10 años de prisión